One of the trademark texts of the American
school system is Harper Lee’s 1960 novel To
Kill a Mockingbird. For decades it has been widely
read in high schools and middle schools an a key
anti-racist text. But how did this novel, with its
Southern Gothic and Bildungsroman elements become
a book that in 2006 the British said “every adult
should read before they die” ahead of the Bible.
That’s a flex.
[Open]
To Kill a Mockingbird was written by Harper
Lee and was loosely based on Lee’s real life
experiences, the book tells the story of
Jean Louise Finch, better known as Scout,
a young girl growing up during the Great
Depression in the fictional town of Maycomb,
Alabama with her older brother Jeremy aka Jem,
and her widowed lawyer father, Atticus Finch.
A name, that will be imprinted
on the world … forever.
Atticus is appointed to defend
a Black man named Tom Robinson,
who is accused of sexually assaulting
a white woman named Mayella Ewell.
This causes a lot of racial harassment towards
the Finch family and at one point in the novel
Atticus has to stop an attempted lynching, with
the help of Scout and some of the other children.
Scout and Jem watch the trial from the
Black section of the courtroom. It is
revealed that Mayella is lying and attempted
to seduce Tom, but was beaten by her father,
who has been sexually abusing his daughter.
Despite being labeled as “white trash”
Tom is convicted for the assault and is
later killed while trying to escape jail.
Mayella’s father, Bob, tries to get revenge
on Atticus by attacking Jem and Scout,
but are saved by the town recluse Boo Radley.
Bob is killed by a knife wound from Radley,
but it is covered up and Scout is
forever changed by this experience.
So who was the mind behind the mockingbird?
Born Nelle Harper Lee in Monroeville, Alabama,
she was also the young daughter of a lawyer father
named Amasa Coleman Lee.
One of her childhood friends,
and long time writing companion was Truman
Capote, who visited their town during the
summers. They would end up living near
each other years later in New York City.
After publishing Mockingbird, Lee
went on a bunch of book tours,
worked on the film adaptation of her book,
and then just went on to lead the successful
life of someone who published one awesome book.
Just one.
One book.
No sequels.
[oh fortuna]
The success of To Kill a Mockingbird was instant
and surpassed the expectations of Lee tenfold.
Professor Alice Hall Petry
wrote in the introduction of
On Harper Lee: Essays and Reflections:
“During the eighty-year period between
1895 and 1975, Mockingbird was the
third-best-selling novel in the United States,
and the seventh-best-selling book of any kind.
Sales have not fallen off in
the ensuing twenty-five years.
In 2001, for example, more than 1
million copies of Mockingbird were sold.”
It has been kept alive through it’s pop
culture influence via the film adaptation,
and being a regularly included text
for middle school children. Of course,
just because a book is taught at school
doesn’t automatically make it popular.
People aren’t this interested in
something like The Scarlet Letter,
and even that wasn’t as huge of
a success when it was released.
UNC chapel hill Professor Emerita Doris
Betts ties it’s longevity to the very
simplistic morality of the text in her essay “The
Mockingbird’s Throat: A Personal Reflection”:
“In Scout Finch, Lee has produced a girl
as appealing as Jo March of Little Women
but stopped her story sooner than Louisa
May Alcott stopped hers, and the point where
initiation became new maturity. By producing no
other novels, Lee also has left readers feeling
that this book has particular significance in that
it contains all she had to say, or all she could.”
And with all of that symbolism and light
discussion of race it raises the question:
what exactly is the value of
teaching To Kill A Mockingbird
versus an actual book about
race written by a Black author?
Gerald Early, professor of
African American Studies, states:
“I read To Kill a Mockingbird the summer before
I read Richard Wright’s Uncle Tom’s Children,
a famous collection of stories by a
black writer about race in the South.
The difference was, of course, astonishing because
the perspectives were so clearly different[…]
The Wright stories taught me two
contradictory but inescapable facts:
first, that books like To Kill a
Mockingbird were inadequate for me
as a black reader and failed, in their
fumbling literal way, to give me black
people as I knew them to be; and second, that
I needed books like To Kill a Mockingbird
if ever I were going to understand the South
as a construction of the white southern mind.”
To Kill A Mockingbird offers some
semblance of safety for white readers
who do not want to feel alienated or
called out by an anti-racist text.
They can see Scout and her father, Atticus,
as a fair depiction of Southern progressivism
and put the legacy of racism and all
it’s terrors on “other white people.”
But it does that, as Professor Isaac Saney writes
in “The Case Against To Kill a Mockingbird”
by making Atticus a white savior
and turning the Black characters
and their community into pawns on Scout’s journey.
“Perhaps the most egregious
characteristic of the novel
is the denial of the historical agency of
Black people. They are robbed of their role
as subjects of history, reduced to mere
objects who are passive hapless victims;
mere spectators and bystanders in the struggle
against their own oppression and exploitation.”
Which brings us to the complex
issues of Atticus Finch himself,
one of literatures great white heroes.
What does the role he plays in the books
actually say about the role white people
play as allies? Well, not much of anything.
According to bad tweeter
Malcolm Gladwell in his essay,
“The Courthouse Ring: Atticus Finch
and the limits of Southern liberalism”:
“Finch will stand up to racists. He’ll use his
moral authority to shame them into silence.
He will leave the judge standing on the
sidewalk while he shakes hands with Negroes.
What he will not do is look at the problem
of racism outside the immediate context
of Mr. Cunningham, Mr. Levy, and the
island community of Maycomb, Alabama.”
Atticus delivering an inspired defense of Tom
Robinson and protecting him has positioned him,
especially in the eyes of white audiences,
as the perfect ally. Until Go Set A Watchman.
And it is at this point I am obligated
to have to discuss Go Set A Watchman.
Remember how Harper Lee only had that one
awesome book? Well, that changed in 2015
when Go Set A Watchman was released. The book’s
road to publication was a controversial one.
The novel was “re-discovered” and Lee
released a statement with Harper Collins:
"In the mid-1950s, I completed a novel
called Go Set a Watchman. It features the
character known as Scout as an adult woman and
I thought it a pretty decent effort. My editor,
who was taken by the flashbacks to Scout's
childhood, persuaded me to write a novel from
the point of view of the young Scout. I was
a first-time writer, so I did as I was told.
I hadn't realized it had survived, so was
surprised and delighted when my dear friend
and lawyer Tonja Carter discovered it. After
much thought and hesitation I shared it with a
handful of people I trust and was pleased to hear
that they considered it worthy of publication.
I am humbled and amazed that this will
now be published after all these years."
Some argued that this “re-discovery”
was suspicious because there were
conflicting reports about the
state of Lee’s mental health
and if this was ever meant to be published.
But people were excited. I mean it is the
sequel to one of the most popular books
of all time … why wouldn’t they publish?
And then it was bad. Like really, really bad.
Alexandra Petri of the Washington
Post said in her review:
“It’s the Jar Jar of classic literature: It
takes place in a beloved fictional universe,
and it’s uncomfortably racist. It has, at best,
a scholarly interest. I can’t imagine that Lee
would want it to represent her in the world.
I don’t think it should have been published.”
Michiko Kakutani for The New York Times
specifically addressed in her piece the big
point that got people upset: the fact that
their beloved Atticus Finch was … racist.
“[...] Atticus is a racist who once attended a
Klan meeting, who says things like “The Negroes
down here are still in their childhood as a
people.” Or asks his daughter: “Do you want
Negroes by the carload in our schools and churches
and theaters? Do you want them in our world?”
In “Mockingbird,” a book once described
by Oprah Winfrey as “our national novel,”
Atticus praised American courts as
“the great levelers,” dedicated to
the proposition that “all men are created
equal.” In “Watchman,” set in the 1950s in
the era of the Brown v. Board of Education
decision, he denounces the Supreme Court,
says he wants his home state “to be left alone
to keep house without advice from the N.A.A.C.P.”
and describes N.A.A.C.P.-paid lawyers
as “standing around like buzzards.”
This was a really awkward moment to be an Atticus.
People were betrayed. It was the last season
of Game of Thrones levels of distraught.
Their Khaleesi turned fascist so
quickly and without warning.
Some people, like Naa Baako Ako-Adjei, a
writer and educator, saw this as another
reason why To Kill A Mockingbird is not that
ideal of a text to teach about anti-racism.
Not simply because it was a very white voice
on Black oppression, but also elements of
classism on which kind of white people are to
“blame” for the situation in Jim Crow America:
“...Lee is certainly not the first Southerner
to blame poor whites for racist violence in the
South; it’s a practice with its own long
history. In 1932, the well-known liberal,
Southern journalist, Gerald White Johnson, wrote
in the then influential North American Review
that “Southerners with money
in the bank do not lynch”
and that lynch mobs were usually composed of
“fellows who have not two nickels to rub together,
those inexpressibly forlorn outcasts known
in the South as the poor white trash.”
...There are, however, moments in the novel
in which you see Lee falter in her attempts
to make only poor whites responsible for the
region’s race problem and absolve ‘fine families’
for the nature of things in the South when she
acknowledges that both rich and poor whites
mistreat black people. “As you grow older,”
Atticus tells Jem, “you’ll see white men
cheat black men every day of your life, but let
me tell you something and don’t forget it—whenever
a white man does that to a black man,
no matter who he is, how rich he is,
or how fine a family he comes from, that
white man is trash” (p. 233). But in the end,
Lee reverts back to scapegoating Bob
Ewell and other poor, ‘white trash.’”
For so long, Mockingbird was able to give
white readers a story to teach them about
racism, but also remove them from any
accountability of perpetuating that system.
They had Atticus to show them that it wasn't
all of them, and Watchman took that away.
When I finally read To Kill a Mockingbird,
for myself in college, I found it a very
readable novel and I got through it fairly
quickly. While well written, and definitely
good, I found myself glad I didn’t read it
for school because the question I found
myself asking is: who is this for?
It is not without merit, but it doesn’t
center Black characters or Black experiences,
it simply observes them through Scout. It is
an introduction to empathy but at a distance,
and that layer of separation is deeply felt.
At least to me. I don’t think we need to stop
teaching To Kill a Mockingbird, but I think
it should be followed up with a Bildungsroman
that actually puts you in the space of a
Black person, rather than a white child.